اذا انتخب الجمهوري كيفن مكارسي رئيسا
لمجلس النواب الامريكي اسرع مخاض عسير
شبته توترات حاد بين اعضاء الحزب الجمهوري
15 جوله لمده اربعه ايام تمكن اخيرا بعدها
الجمهوريه ابن كارثه بالفوز بمنصب رئيس
مجلس النواب الامريكي مقارس الذي حصل على
فوز صعب اقر خلال مؤتمر الصحفي بان الرئيس
السابق ترامب ادى دورا حااسما في انتزاع
اخر الاصوات اللازمه للانتخابات بدوره هنا
الرئيس
الانتخابيه رئيسا لمجلس النواب ودعاه الى
الحكم بشكل مسؤول و لصالح الامريكين بحسب
قوله
اجنده كيفن ماكرتي رئيس مجلس النواب الان
بدا العمل الشاق والاهم
الجمهوريون الذين باتوا يسيطرون على مجلس
النواب تعاهدوا باطلاق سلسله من التحقيقات
في سبل اداره الرئيس لجائزه كورونا
وقرار الانسحاب من افغانستان
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من واشنطن
هاب عباس المحلل السياسي بعد قليل كذلك
سينضم لنا من واشنطن الدكتور ادم غريب
الاستاذ في العلاقات الدوليه اا خليني
ابدا معك استاذ عباس بعد متابعتنا ارحب بك
قبل كل شيء واا بعد متابعتنا في الواقع
لمختلف هذه الجلسات لمحاوله انتخاب رئيس
مجلس النواب بعد مخاض عسير في الواقعه وما
تخلله من انتقادات وفشل وحتى اتهامات
بالخيانه طالت اعضاء او بعض اعضاء الحزب
الجمهوري في النهايه تمكنان كيفن مكرسي من
تامين مطرقه مجلس النواب ولكن يبقى السؤال
هل هو الشخص المناسب في المكان المناسب
بالنسبه لحزبه اولا قبل الحديث عن مجلس
النواف العموم
اهلا بحضرتك شكرا على الاستضافه واهلا بكل
المشاهدين انا اعتقد ان اكيب المكارسي هو
الشخص المناسب في الوقت الحالي السبب في
ذلك يعود اولا لانه يبقى دعم كبير جدا من
الجمهوريين في العموم والرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب الذي اعلنت ترشحه للانتخابات
الرئاسيه القادمه بالاضافه الى ان ما حدث
من اختلاف وجهات النظر ادى الى اطاله امد
انتخابه كرئيس لمجلس النواب الامريكي كان
امرا جيدا للجمهوريين واشرح لماذا جيدا
للجمهوريه اولا الجمهوريون
العشرون الذين كانوا يعترضون حققوا مطالب
هامه جدا بسبب اعتراضيهم على تولي مكارثي
لهذا المنصب المطلب الاول هو امكانيه ان
يحرك عضو واحد فقط من مجلس النواب همم
طلبا ل- اا احداث همم عمليه تصويت على
ملائمه رئيس المجلس من عدمه لشغل هذا منصب
هذا الامر كان قد اقترح وتم الموافقه عليه
في اللوائح الداخليه للكونجرس اابانه فتره
اا نانسي باللوسي وافق على هذا الامر انه
كان ينوي ان يلغيه فيما يبدو الامر الاخر
انه وافق ايضا
على اعطاء اللجان التشكيل لجنه خاصه تقوم
بالتحقيق بمتابعه
التحقيقات التي تجري في احداث همم السادس
من يناير بما يضمن همم حريه وامن
الامريكيين بمعنى ان هذه الاجنه ستدخل في
التحقيقات التي تجريها الشرطه وزالت وزاره
العدل الامريكيه ل- اا التاكد من ان هذه
التحقيقات لا تسير بشكل مفرد ومخالف
للقانون ضد الامريكيين خاصه هؤلاء الذين
اعترضوا على فوزين وهذا سيؤدي الى مشكلات
كبيره خلال الفتره القادمه في الداخل
الامريكي همم من بين ايضا هذه الخطوات
كانت مهمه ايضا هي اعطاء النواب 72 ساعه
للاطلاع على مشاريع القوانين قبل ان
يصوتوا عليها لان النائب عندما يذهب الى
المجلس لا تكون امامه فرصه كافيه للاطلاع
على القانون فيكون هناك تصويت القطيع يعني
همم طالما وفق مجموعه كبيره او وافق انا
ايضا رفض ذلك الامر قالوا نريد ان يكون
التصويت لا لديه مده كافيه كل نائب حتى
يستطيع ان يقوم بعمليه التصوير اذا الرجل
اصبح همم مكتوفا همم بهذه الموافقات التي
التي قدمها والتنازلات التي قدمها لهؤلاء
الاعضاء وهذا سيكون جيدا للحزب الجمهوري
لماذا لان الحزب الجمهوري اليوم في توجهه
العام داخل مجلس النواب هو في اقصى اليمين
هذا اكثر همم يعني همم مره هذه اكثر مره
يكون فيها الجمهوريون يمنيين جدا في داخل
مجلس النواب بالاضافه الى انه بدات هناك
تسريبات بال- همم القرارات التي سيسعى
لاتخاذها مجلس النواب وعلى راسهم كارسي
مثلا وقف التمويل الذي سيكون ممنوحا من
قبل اداره كان هناك مشروع قراء قانون بذلك
ل 87.000 عميل من عملاء همم وكاله همم
الخدمات الضريبيه الامريكيه الانترنت همم
سيرفسز
وقال مكارتي تحديدا قال لن نقدم هذا الدعم
المتناهي لهؤلاء لان على وكاله الضرائب ان
تقوم بمساعده الامريكين وليس بملاحقتهم
وسيقوم بتخفيض ايضا الميزانيات الحكوميه
والانفاق الحكومي باقل من السقف الذي كانت
تحاول اداره
الانفاق ولكن عن رفع نسبه الديون الباص
كذلك يرى مخاطر بخصوص هذا الموضوع على كل
ينضم لنا كذلك همم الاستاذ حسين عبد حسين
الباحث في مؤسسه الدفاع عن الديمقراطيات
اهلا بك دكتور معنا كنا نتحدث مع ضيفنا
الاستاذ ايهاب عن همم
تامين الجمهوريين لمطرقه رئاسه مجلس
النواب والى اي مدى ربما ما همم كارت
سيكون الشخص المناسب بالنسبه الاستاذ
ايهاب يا ربي انه شخص مناسب في المكان
المناسب بان اعضاء الحزب قيد بمجموعه من
الالتزامات
وعليه سيتحرك همم بما يساعد او بما ينفع
الحزب حضرتك همم هل توافق همم هذا همم هذه
القراءه
اعتقد انه التقييد هو ضعف للحزب الجمهوري
وهو ضعف لكادر يعني كيف سيتفاوض مكان في
مع الديمقراطيين ومع الرئيس فايدن وهو
بالكاد همم نجح في التفاوض باسمه للحصول
على مطرقه رئاسه
فهذا الضعف سي ينعكس او سيؤدي الى شلل
كبير انه اذا كان الحزب الجمهوري غير قادر
على دفع مرشحه لقيادته كيف يمكن لهذا
المرشح الذي يقود اليوم ان همم يوصل الحزب
الجمهوري لاي اتفاقيه مع الحزب الديمقراطي
هو طبعا كما تفضل استاذ ايهاب الحزب
الجمهوري حاليا هو في اقصى اقصى اليمين ما
يجعل اي تسويه مع الديمقراطيين شبه
مستحيله والتسويات ضروريه لان الكونجرس
اصلا منقسم الغالبيه في النواب للجمهوريين
والغالبيه في الشيوخ الديمقراطين والرئاسه
الديمقراطين فكيف يمكن اداره بلد او اداره
موازنه او اداره زي معه ورفع سقف
الاستدانه مع هذا الانقسام وناس في اقصى
اليمين وناس في اليسار وناس في الوسط
اعتقد انه هذا سيعقل الامور اكثر بكثير من
ما كان يتصور اي منا قبل يعني او حتى بعد
ظهور نتائج الانتخابات
او بالعكس سيحل الامور اكثر لما نتحدث
كذلك عن تعقيد الامور نستذكر ما جاء على
لسان بعض همم
المتمردين او من اسمائهم بالمتمردين في
الجلسات الاولى عرضوا التصويت لمكارسي
وقالوا حتى بان من ساء يصوت له ويصوت
لشخصه لحسابه الخاص وليس للحزب وبان مصالح
الحزب لا تتوافق معها كذا شخصيه هل هذه
الانقسامات يمكن ان تضر ليس فقط بالحزن
وانما حتى في مشروع الحزب مع البيت الابيض
هو مخطط بيضا
يعني اكيد بكل تاكيد يعني فكره
الانقسامات ستكون لها تاثيرات السلبيه على
اي طرف من الاطراف هذا يعني لا جدا فيه
ولكن هناك فرق بين الانقسام بسبب التاكد
او رغبه التاكد من ان الشخص الذي سيمثل
هؤلاء وكل الجمهورينا في مجلس النواب
سيخضع للتوجه الجمهوري اليميني تماما ام
انه سيريد تحقيق بعض التوافقات مع
الديمقراطين في ملفات المعينه الجمهوريين
يبدو انه يدخلون مجلس النواب بعد عدم رغبه
للتوافق مع الديمقراطيين في اي من الملفات
الكبرى التي يرون ان الديمقراطيين اهملوها
او تصرفه فيها بالشكل غير اللائق
للامريكيين
افغانستان
بعد نتائج الانتخابات الاوليه قالوا بانه
همم سنطرح نقاط بخصوص تحقيقات بخصوص
محاوله ايجاد الحقيقه في ما يخص مثلا
طريقه خروج الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من
افغانستان طرح حتى ملف عزل بايدن هل تعتقد
بان هذه الملفات ستطرح من جديد على
الطاوله
ستطرح طبعا ولكن هناك ستكون هناك فروقات
بمعنى ملف عزل انا اعتقد انه في نهايه
المطاف سيكون مضيعه للوقت لان الجمهوريون
ليسوا مسيطرين على مجلس الشيوخ الذي سيذهب
في نهايه المطاف اليه هذا الملف برمته
باتهاماته بقرائته بادلته بكل شيء وفي
نهايه المطاف يحتاج الديمقراطيون للادانه
والعزل الى ثلثي همم همم تشكيله المجلس
الشيوخ هذا لن يتحقق لعدم سيدارته سيطرهم
على مجلس فاعتقد الناس ستكون اضاعه الوقت
ولكن ربما يقومون بها نهايه الديمقراطيين
كما فعلوا قبل ذلك مع الرئيس دونالد ترامب
ربما يكون التفكير في هذا الاطار لكن فكره
همم تحقيقات افغانستان ربما تكون مجديه
همم كما قلت الحقيقه قبل ذلك همم فكره
اللجان التي اللجنه التي ستتشكل
لمتابعه تحقيقات سير العمل همم سير
التحقيقات التي تجري بسبب احداث في يناير
هذه ايضا من الممكن ان يخلق مشكلات كبيره
مع جهات انفاد القانون ومع البيت الابيض
ايضا وبالتالي اعتقد الجمهوريين خلال
الفتره القادمه سيكون لديهم اربعه او خمسه
ملفات كبرى سيتعاملون فيها بحزم شديد ومن
بينها طبعا ملف ايران النووي والمفاوضات
الفاشله التي تقوم بها او كانت تقوم بها
الاداره الامريكيه حتى اليوم اداره بادن
ولم تحقق نهائيا
وفي هذا الاطار
الاستاذ حسين الباز يقول بان الحسبه
الجمهوري يشهد حتى انقسامات بخصوص تمويل
همم اوكرانيا يعني همم هناك بعض مما يرى
بانه يجب وقف امداد اوكرانيا بالمساعدات
ووقف تمويل الاوكرانيا والصقور الحزب يرون
بانه لا يجب التخلي على اوكرانيا في هذا
الاطار وبعد توليفارسي لرئاسه مجلس النواب
الى اين ستتجه الامور
اعتقد انه ما سنراه في الغالب هو انقسام
في الجمهوريين
داخل صفوف الحزب الجمهوري في كل تصويت
يجري حول الموازنه او رفع سقف الاستدانه
لانه لم يحدث انقسام يستحيل التوصل يعني
يؤدي الانقسام الى اقفال تمويل او وقف
تمويل الحكومه الفدراليه والاخطر من ذلك
وقف رفع سقف الاستدانه ما يعني انه الارجح
سينقسم الجمهوريون وسيمضم
اصوات الديمقراطيين الى جمهوريين ممن
يوافقون مما يتواصلون الى تسويه ما بين
الاثنين يعني تكون
التصويت هو عباره عن الغالبيه من الحزبين
مع انشقاقات من يعني بين الجمهوريين لن
يصوت المتطرفون الجمهوري لن يستطيع ذلك
المتطرفون
الديمقراطورته هذا سيحصل في الغالب لتصويت
على الموازنه وعلى رفع صقر الاستبانه
واعتقد انه
رانيا تمويل اوكرانيا غالبا ما يندرج كبند
تحت الموازنه العامه لذلك يعني حتى لو
سمعنا اصوات تعارض التمويل اعتقد انه في
نهايه المطار التمويل سيستمر لانه هناك
غالبيه لدى الحزبين تؤيد هذا التمويل
وهناك طبعا معارضه لدى الحزبين ولكن لا
اعتقد انه معارضه في ايمن الحسبان ستنجح
في تقليص او وقف هذا التمر
لما نتحدث عن تمويل هناك تمويل من تمويل
وهناك مسانده من مسانده قد ايه همم تتغير
الامور وقد تختلف كذلك حتى معايير
المسانده وتعريف المسانده كيف ستتم خاصه
لما نستذكر علاقه الجمهوريين ببوتين مثلا
علاقه ترامب لم تكون بهذا السوق فهل تعتقد
بانه مع كارت سيتغير شيء بهذا الخصوص
يعني انا اتفق مع الضيف العزيز بفكره انه
من الممكن ان يكون هناك
من فكره ان ان هناك توافق بين عدد كبير من
الجمهورينا وديمقراطيين في وجوب تمويل
اوكرانيا ولكن الجمهوريون اليوم لن يقدمه
هذا الدعم المطلق وهذا ما قاله مكارثي
بنفسه يعني هذا الرجل الذي اليوم يوصف
بانه ضعيف او اصبح غير قادر على اداره
المجلس هو الذي قال لن نمنح اوكرانيا شيكا
على بياض وهذا ايضا ما يؤكده الاعضاء
اليمنيون جدا داخل مجلس النواب من
الجمهوريه وبالتالي
القدرات الاداره الامريكيه على مستوى
البيت الابيض والخارجيه وزاره الدفاع
ستكون محدوده بشكل او باخر بفكره التموين
لن يكون هناك تمويل مطلق له اوكرانيا يعني
انا اعتقد انك تمويل الاوكراني سيخف بنسبه
50% على الاقل تقدير لان الجمهوريين لديهم
والجهات
اولا لتخفيض الانفاق الحكومي
ولديهم احداث هذه القدره لان مجلس النواب
هو المعني بهذا الامر تحديدا فكره
الميزانيات واعتمادها ولديهم ايضا ااا
رغبات في اعطاء المواطن الامريكي في
المقابل
الاهتمام الاكبر من الانفاق الحكومي الذي
هم ايضا يريدون في نهايه المطاف ان يحد
منه يعني هما الجمهوريين عاده لا يرغبون
في احداث الانفاق الحكومي في المطلق كما
يقوم الديمقراطيون ولذلك ستكون هناك لديهم
حدود محسوبه جدا في مساله هذا الانفاق
ولكن سيتم توجيه القدر الاكبر منه قدر
المستطاع للداخل الامريكي وليس
التطورات وكيف سيكون التعامل فيما يخص كل
هذه الملفات او اتشقراء شكر
عباس المحلله السياسيه ومن واشنطن كذلك
حسين عبد حسين الباحث في مؤسسه الدفاع عن
الديمقراطيهات شكرا لكم